notre boîte à souvenirs nous transporte
aujourd'hui en 1999
l'automne c'est la saison des citroën
mais c'est aussi la saison des concours
de citrouilles géantes à ottawa la
semaine verte avait rencontré un
passionné de ces monstres orangé
[Musique]
les graines le secret scellé quel type
où ça vient si le secret c'est la graine
encore faut-il savoir quoi en faire un
petit coup de papier sablé lui permettra
d'absorber l'eau plus rapidement pour
accélérer le processus de germination
une fois les graines sablé et tremper
dans l'eau et leur gré elles sont
placées dans un contenant hermétique à
85 degrés fahrenheit soit 28 degrés
celsius après 24 à 48 heures
le racing doit l'être commence à sentir
quelques semaines seulement les plans
déjà pris des proportions étonnantes
les fleurs font leur apparition et c'est
le moment de la pollinisation une étape
d'une importance capitale car si d'ici
peu des croisements sont faits et que
les chances d'obtenir la plus grosse
citrouille commence à ce calcul est un
peu de fertilisants et beaucoup d'eux un
seul plan citrouilles géantes peut boire
jusqu'à 220 litres d'eau par jour
un mois seulement après la pollinisation
les citrouilles atteignent déjà des
dimensions impressionnantes
certains de ces géants ont peuvent
croître entre 10 et 15 kg par jour là la
plus grosse citrouille au monde
dépassés lit on sent livre c'est plus
d'une demi tonne aujourd'hui
ce record a doublé pour atteindre en 100
kg
et la grande question dans une villa
combien de temps peut donner une
citrouille de cette dimension est bien
aucune parce que la chair des cidres
géant n'est pas suffisamment le sucré
pour en faire de la tarte
mais qu'à cela ne tienne ses citrouilles
bien que ton combustible est difficile à
transporter votre décan l'excellent pour
empire sorciers des mondes des fantômes
le soir de la louve